I look at Rodney's line with his eyes
open but he can't do anything oh and
John says doctor said he can hear us but
he can't respond
so I'm telling how much we love him how
great he was to all his Comics right
so Joan says to me yeah Jay
put your finger in Rodney's hand she
goes Rodney if you know it's Jay try and
squeeze his finger so I put my finger in
the hand I feel like a just a slight
squeeze and I went Rodney that's not my
finger
and Rodney's shoulders don't like a
jungle he moved him yeah and well you
know and so he died right after that but
to get him to get a laugh oh my God I
mean it was like God you know I I don't
mean that to be a cruel story that's a
great story but it's just
hey
[Music]